[Applaudissements]
nous sommes lundi première abri et ses
touches pas mon quotidien merci d'être
avec nous dans un instant on recevra le
petit virtuose de la flûte électronique
michel stroganoff qui sera avec nous
dans un instant michel qui reçoit un
carton hongrie qui sera avec nous bien
sûr dans quelques instants c'est la
révélation vous le savez hongroise de
flûte électronique on aura également
d'ailleurs c'est un instrument qui a
fait parler de lui j'ai entendu ou pas
par les doigts tout électrique
[Musique]
ça n'allait pas
[Applaudissements]
et
oh mon dieu
des mots
les millions du csa au lever moi-même
tout le reste mais pas la fraude aux
deux rats mais il m'a pas lâché une
seconde il devenait ma table de ping
pong
prenez moi tout mais pépettes mais
laissez moi ma trottinette ou le monde
aux manches devant des rivaux pour des
comptes la pieuvre est la plus de
cerveaux que tout le monde ici chaque
bateau rien accompli 9 cerveau lui bras
et trois coeurs s est enfin elle est
très intelligente que la pieuvre dsk
incroyable quand on regarde la la
pieuvre et c'est qu'il ya treize prix
nobel qui ont étudié des choses dans la
mer sont pas là une dentellière une
d'anthony oui aux reflets dit vous qu'en
d'autres temps ci sont retrouvés une
dentellière aux reflets chocolat
[Applaudissements]
m
[Rires]
[Musique]
elle va s'en prendre à un peu loin at en
fait je m'approchais bon niveau ici les
bonnes tables des pop up
bonsoir alors tu as beaucoup d'amis avec
toi
[Musique]
eh bien regardez ce qui s'est passé hier
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
regardez moi par exemple à sheffield a
dit regardez chez la liste de tous les
chroniqueurs je vais virer d'année
prochaine
gelé la halle et là malheureusement je
ne peux pas le dire les trop longues
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui bonjour je suis bien la gueule à la
gueule du loup
bonjour vous êtes vous êtes toujours là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qui n'engage vous montrer comment ça
se danse à sedan si vous êtes chez vous
tranquillement les gens de métier
si tu es
[Musique]
alors nous explique cette partie là du
corps ne bouge pas cette partie là nous
ça se passe bien
et
si tu es
salah
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
s
[Musique]
pasqua dans les profondeurs mais
vraiment j'ai profondeurs allant fond de
la mer où il ya des soirées mousse là
[Applaudissements]
il ya des dégâts
on a reçu vanille et c'est vrai qu'à un
moment je me suis dit pourquoi on reçoit
pas chocolat
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
qui
/
comme le chocolat
[Applaudissements]